bon nous allons commencer sans plus
attendre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues donc nous avons l'honneur et
le plaisir de recevoir ce matin Monsieur
Philippe Vigier ministre des aux outrem
auprès du ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremes monsieur Gérald armanin nous
avions également convié celui-ci mais
l'actualité chargée que vous connaissez
ne lui permet pas d'être parmi nous
aujourd'hui et il vous prie de l'en
excuser je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation de faire un point sur votre
feuille de route pour les outres mes
juste avant l'examen des crédits de
votre ministère dans l'hémicycle nous
attendons de votre part que vous vous
nous éclaireer sur la vision et les
engagements du gouvernement pour nos
outremèes il y a quelques jours les élus
ont été reçus pour un bilan d'étape du
comité interministériel des outremèes
leum nous souhaitons en particulier vous
entendre sur les leçons que vous tirez
de ces récents échanges après votre
propos liminire nos collègues pourront
vous faire part de leurs remarques ou
préoccupations comme nous sommes une
instance paritaire avec autant
d'ultramarin que de collègues hexagonaux
la délégation apporte aussi un regard
coroisé sur nos territoires et les
politiques qui sont menées la présente
audition s'inscrit par ailleurs dans la
perspective des prochains travaux de la
délégation que je laisserai au
rapporteur désigner le soin d'évoquer je
ne serai pas plus longue j'annonce à
tous que nous suspendrant la réunion à
10h et chacun est donc appelé à la
concision lors de son intervention afin
de permettre à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent de poser leurs questions donc
je vais vous céder la parole monsieur le
ministre mais avant euh pour des raisons
pratiques je demanderai à tous ceux qui
souhaitent intervenir de s'inscrire sur
la boucle WhatsApp nous poserons les
questions par trois et Monsieur le
Ministre répondra de manière à permettre
à tout le monde euh d'intervenir je vous
remerci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
suis très heureux d'être ce matin devant
la délégation aux outrem euh vous saluez
toutes et toutes et vous dire que d'Urs
c'est au Sénat qu'on on a cette audition
qui nous permet d'établir la feuille de
route l'assemblée nous avons démarré
directement par des opérations liées au
budget euh donc il on été nommé par le
Président de la République et la
première ministre le 21 juillet dernier
c'estd 3 jours après l'adoption du
fameux comité interministériel de Ultrem
qui vous le savez sur de la première
ministre Géral larmmanin avait validé 72
mesures qui étai qui avaient répondu à
l'appel des Fort de France qui a été
lancé plusieurs mois auparavant et pour
lequel le président de la République
avait souhaité que l'on puisse apporter
une réponse pour les utremèes et donner
un nouvel élan à ces territoire
ultramarin d'abord ma feuille de route
elle passe par la rencontre avec tous
les acteurs dans chacun des territoire
pour être extrêmement concret et précis
je serais allé partout lorsque j'aurais
pu enfin faire ce voyage à VO Futuna qui
aura lieu ce déplacement qui aura lieu
au mois de janvier qui devait être
réalisé auparavant mais à la dernière
minute j'ai dû pass Gérald haranin à
l'Assemblée je m'envole tout à l'heure
pour maotte avec la première ministre
j'imagine que les parlementaires les
sénateurs seront présents n'est-ce
pas un nouveau déplacement dont on
pourra parler si vous le souhaitez
deuxièmement je suis allez déjà quatre
fois à Mayotte trois fois à la Réunion
je suis allz bien sûr en Guadeloupe en
Martinique à Saint-Martin à Saint-Bart
je suis allé bien sûr en guyan et je
pars à Saint-Pierre Milon dimanche
après-midi et il ne restera donc Wiss et
Futuna mais vous savez que pour aller à
waliss et Futuna c'est un délai de de 5
jours pour des raisons que chacun peut
comprendre l'exigence étant de passer
par né donc la première chose c'est d'
la rencontre de tous ces territoires et
d'être à l'écoute de voir tous les
acteurs chaque déplacement chaque voyage
officiel permettant au-delà des
rencontres avec tous les acteurs autour
du préfet bien sûr la rencontre des élus
des
sociopressionnels dans toutes les
activités je suis allé voir à la
rencontre des SMMA puceque vous savez
que nous avons une impentation très
forte des SMMA dans chaque des
territoires sauf à Saint-Martin
Saint-Bart de manière à pouvoir avec
celles et ceux qui sont en charge de de
ces territoires ultrarin évoquer leurs
attentes leurs difficultés leurs
contraintes la deuxième chose qui était
pour moi essentielle c'était bien sûr
que la politique ultramarine ne se
limite pas auum elle est extrêmement
large vous vous êtes en pleine phase
budgétaire vous savez qu'au-delà des 3
milliards d'euros de de financement des
territoires ultramarins pour les 2024
tout ministère confondu ces 22 milliards
d'euros qui sont directement concerné
pour les politiques ultramarines faut
dire que ma
deuxè le deuxième point de la feuille de
route ma deuxième exigence c'est de
faire en sorte que nous soyons dans
l'interministériel à tout moment
pourquoi dans l'interministériel à tout
moment parce que lorsque vous êtes en
charge des ultremèes il y a dans les
ultremèes toutes les politiques
naturellement ministérielles qui sont
déclinées que ce soit l'éducation que ce
soit le logement que soit la santé hier
après-midi avec agès firm le baudau et
certains d'entre vous nous avions une
rencontre très importante dans le cas
d'ailleurs d' des mesures du sium mais
une mesure qui conduit à porter
l'exigence de faire en sorte que la
prise en charge des cancers ne soit pas
comme elle l' à l'heure actuelle
extrêmement décalée en et retardé par
rapport à ce qu'on vit dans l'Hexagone
donc vous voyez que c'est un exemple
mais ces exemples c'était avec Patrick
verriet puisquil y a une loi sur le
logement qui
va que vous le savez arrivver en début
d'année 2024 c'est comment on décline
cette loi dans les territoires
ultr-amarins avec une exigence qui est
porté par par la première ministre et ça
c'est important à mes yeux c'est que on
arrête enfin d'avoir une déclinaison
ultramarine qui soit la même que la
déclinaision hexagonale et vous en avez
une illustration très forte c'est vous
savez qu'il y a des discussions qui ont
lieu depuis longtemps vois le sénateur
Lurel ancien ministre qui est là il le
sait parfaitement le le le projet des
normes RUP e Cece norm RUP qui vont
pouvoir s'appliquer par dérogation au N
l'Union européenne dans le mois de mars
2024 et qui pourra les territoire
ultramarin c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel parce que c'est un des
moyens de lutter contre la vie chè vie
chè permet de dire que dans la feuille
de route avec Bruno Le Maire avec Gérald
dermanin hier j'ai voyais Thomas casenav
comment demain on envisage une politique
budgétaire qui soit aussi distincte pour
les territoires ultramarin car celle-ci
elle embrasse tous les domaines elle
embrasse le logement elle embrasse la
TGAP est une question n'est-ce pas la
sénatrice mé a beaucoup écrit interpellé
sur ce sujet parce que le sujet des des
déchets est un sujet qu'on vit partout
faut pas regarder ultramarin comme les
mauvais élèves de la classe moi qui
connais bien l'Hexagone où j'ai devant
moi un sénateur de d'indrloir que je
connais bien qui était prise dans un
département dans lequel c'était une
question qui n'a jamais pu être résolue
donc vous voyez que tout cela ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'à un moment ou
un autre on doit travailler
interministériel premier plan vous
l'avez compris c'est la rencontre avec
tous les acteurs le deuxième sujet c'est
faire de l'interministériel la troisème
sujet c'est de faire le dialogue
permanent parce que je vois bien à quel
point un certain nombre de questions
n'ont pas été suffisamment approfondies
en tout cas euh ma métode c'est avant
tout de la concertation c'est raison
pour laquelle ça m'a amené dans le cadre
du cum je rappelle que cette feuille de
route du 18 juillet
2023 défini par la la première ministre
qui devait avoir une clause de revoyure
en clair qu'on fasse un bilan d'étape
une année après nont pas attendu et le
bonheur et la joie d'accueillir tous les
parlementaires tous les grands élus vous
étiez bien sûr là madame la Présidente
tous les présidents de l'Association des
Maires parce que je pense qu'il y a
aucune construction qui peut se faire si
les acteurs ne sont pas là et donc
chaque territoire eu un temps qui lui a
été dédié euh donc c'était je crois un
moment important et puis le soir la
charnière entre les deux jours et voyez
blessé que je suis parce que je me sens
totalement ultraarin que par exemple
France 2030 qui est un deie absolument
puissant plus de 50 milliards d'euros
d'investissement possible avec Bruno bel
le secrétaire général on s'aperçoit que
nous sommes en nous étions à 55 millions
d'euros de consommation en lier nous
sommes passés à 125 millions mais nous
sommes très très loin de l'hexagone et
ça n'est pas acceptable et par exemple
j'avais fait venir également thbaau
Guill qui vient d'être nommé vous savez
patron de France travail parce que il
n'y avait pour l'instant que la Réunion
qui était territoire
expérimentateur pour justement
l'expérimentation France travail telle
qu'elle avait été décliné et il y avait
en plus business France qui était
représenté parce que ça me paraissait
essentiel que là encore la nouvelle
économie les start-ups l'innovation la
recherche soit au rendez-vous
ensuite cette relation qui nous avons
établie dans cette feuille de route il y
a naturellement des priorités la santé
je dit tout à l'heure d'ailleurs auréien
Rousseau sera du déplacement avec la
premère ministre et et votre serviteur
autour de la autour à Mayotte et nous
aurons un tour d'horizon complet je sais
les difficultés que rencontre en matière
de santé au-delà uniquement de sujet des
cancer les établissements de de santé
ultramarin et par exemple sur la Réunion
on a commencé à porter une première
réponse pas la signénatrice puisque le
fameux coefficient géographique a été
augmenté d'un point et demi pour de 2024
il le sera également vous le savez pour
2025 c'est une partie du chemin je
connais les difficultés en Guadeloupe
partout et elles sont parfaitement
intégré sur le le sujet bien sûr
extrêmement important de de logement on
y reviendra probablement dans les
questions il y a le sujet du foncier
pour la Guyane on commence enfin à
avancer un peu c'est tellement difficile
encore des petits sujets sur la Safire à
finir de régler mais
conseiladministration est en place les
financements sont en place d'être
définitivement validé et d'après les
informations précises que nous avons pu
obtenir il y a quelques jours là où il y
avait pas eu vous savez dans les accords
2016 pour la Guyane le respect par
l'état des transferts des fonciers pour
la Saffire par la saffaire et du moins
aux collectivités on sera on devrait
être au moins 20000 heares à la fin de
l'année 2024 qui est quand même un bon
en avant c'est vrai qu'on est très loin
de l'objectif de 240000 hectares mais ça
veut dire que quand même il y a eu cette
avancée et le logement on y reviendra
probablement dans dans le dans le débat
avec la LBU avec la politique conduite
hors quartier politique de la ville avec
l'augmentation des des taux
d'intervention de de l'ANA et un moment
où le périmètre des grands des projets
de ville est en train d'évoluer et nous
serons donc présents sur l'eau la
saénissement par que c'est une question
qui revient sans arrêt vous savez que
puissamment l'État est auprès des
collectivités je vois tan sénateur de
bot aussi et vous le savez je crois on
est en train d'aider considér blement
maotte mais nous le faisons parce que
l'État aussi doit avoir cette notion de
solidarité au moment où difficultés
majeures sont là pour la Guadeloupe avec
le SMAG qui je crois est très largement
aidé on a signé un beau contrat il y a
peu de temps un vrai partenariat avec la
région avec le département 320 millions
d'euros avec risations concrète et
attendu et sur l'assaainissement je sais
qu'il il y a beaucoup de des questions
qui sont sous-jacentes et en tout cas
nous serons là enfin le dernier mot
comme ça je n'aurai pas plus trop de
temps j'espère madame la Présidente sur
domain économique Lero de mer on en
parlera bien sûr comme vous le souhaitez
en tout cas je tiendrai les engagements
tel qu'ils ont pu être définis si je
résume en une minute l'engagement c'est
une construction rien n'est écrit rien
nétait décidé il y a pas de réforme
cachée je sais trop vous me connaissez
tous que j'ai été maire pendant 16 ans
président comité de commune cons
régional encore combien le TR de maire
est vital pour les communes combien le
est vital pour les régions combien aussi
il est pas compris par nos compatriotes
comment il s'applique aussi de façon
anormale sur certaines productions
locales alors que c'était pas
originellement ce qui avait été conçu
donc cette réforme il faut la RÉIR
ensemble donc la logique qui a été
définie dans ces bilan du sium et pouvez
être témoin madame la Présidente c'est
d'abord une étape territoriale auut des
préfets les présidents de collectivité
les parlementaires vous êtes
parlementaires longtemps je peux pas
laisser des tuau différents tout le
monde doit être connecté ça me paraît
indispensable que cette coconstruction
se fasse à avec les maires les
parlementaires les présidents de
collectivité les consommateurs parce que
quelque part aussi le consommateur c'est
celui qui va remplir le cadis et puis
naturellement en présence du monde
économique et d'ailleurs le 4 décembre
j'ai réevenu le monde économique au
ministère et je le réérer régulièrement
et tout dernier mot c'est qu'il y a en
matière de transition énergétique des
protections de l'environnement des
énergies renouvelables je crois des
potentialité assez exceptionnelles assez
extraordinaire et qui sont pas toujours
faciles c'est vrai à conduire mais
rassurez-vous dans dans l'Hexagone ça
est tout autant tout autant compliqué
hein bien placé pour le savoir dans mon
territoire et vous dire aussi que la
biodiversité qui qui on retrouve à 85 %
dans les territoires ultramarin et bien
elle doit être plus que jamais protégée
et vous dire aussi que par exemple pour
l'agriculture qui est assez proche euh
là on a des leviers de croissance et
important d'ailleurs dans le budget mais
vous savez certainement c'est qu'au-delà
du posi et bien on passera l'aide
nationale de 45 à 60 millions d'euros et
on a je crois fait un travail euh déjà
de proximité avec les collectivités mais
on continuera de le faire voilà en
quelques mots donc une peut-être propos
paraît-il décousu mais vous avez compris
un de la proximité euh deux de rendre
des comptes parce que je pense que c'est
indispensable trois de le trouver les
Levi d'efficacité de manière à ce que
sur le logement le pouvoir d'achat et la
production locale encore l'autonomie
fiscale des territoires et l'omie
l'autonomie énergétique il y a qu'un
sujet que je n'ai pas traité c'est je le
fais pour terminer ce propos introductif
c'est celui de les évolutions
institutionnelles là c'est très simple
le président de la République a réuni
vous le savez tous les parlementaires
tous les grands élus des collectivités
et présidentassociation des maires
autour de lui de la première vie de
galde hermanin et de moi-même au mois
d'octobre a été défini une méthode la
méthode passera par la nomination des
personnalités qualifié maintenant je
crois que c'est une affaire de quelques
jours qui rend rencontre des acteurs des
différents territoires à qui on
demandera quels sont les souhaits
d'évolution d'article 73 74 quelles sont
les choses que voudrait voir modifi
après on verra comment dans le cadre
soit c'est initiative soit c'est une
réforme constitutionnelle c'est réformme
constitutionnelle comment on fait mais
là aussi la BAL doit être aussi dans les
territoire que il y a des propositions
et que tout ne vienne pas de Paris en
vertical et justement cetteiration
puisse se faire à l'échelle de chacun
des territoires voilà madame messieurs
les sénateurs madame la Présidente
quelques mots je souhaitais prononcer au
démarrage de cette
audition je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre nous avons déjà demandes de
prise de parole donc je vais laisser la
parole à à notre collègue Marie Laure
finirort puis Audré bellim et saidïd
Omar Oli
oui bonjour à tous merci présidente
alors Monsieur le Ministre j'ai j'ai
deux sujets le premier qui s'adresse
surtout à Monsieur Darmanin mais qui
n'est pas là mais peu importe vous êtes
là vous en fait il s'agit du dispositif
sans% contrôle vous savez que la Guyane
c'est la plaque tourmente de
l'acheminement de la drogue vers vers
l'Europe et je voyage régulièrement et
je suis souvent interpellé par les
forces de l'ordre en fait qui effectuent
ses contrôles mais qui sont exténués
parce que euh les mules continuent en
tout cas continuent à tenter de passer
il y en a qui passent et il y en a qu'on
attrappe mais c'est fatiguant et je
pense que il y a y a une solution qu'on
propose nous c'est la nécessité
d'installer un scan capable de relever
les objets ingérés comme un chipole
parce que
moi je vois pas le bout du rouleau en
fait il y a les 100 % contrôle les
policiers sont là la mission d'un
policier ben c'est assurer la la la
protection d'un citoyen or il se
retrouve là à l'aéroport alors souvent
il y a 50 personnes refoulées et puis il
y a un autre problème monsieur le
ministre c'est que lorsque les personnes
sont refoulées on ne récupère pas le
produit ils repartent dans la nature
avec leurs produits il y a quatre gardes
à vue pas plus c'est pas possible il
faut il faut trouver une solution et la
deuxème question vous con parce que je
reste dans le domaine du transport
aérien alors j'ai été interpellé par un
groupe d'antio guyanais par rapport à la
charé du billet en fait ma question est
simple elle est simple que comptez-vous
faire monsieur le ministre pour
permettre à nos compatriotes de voyager
avec un prix au kilomètre acceptable
parce que c'est compliqué c'est cher
c'est très très cher 1200 € pour
quelqu'un qui veut venir à Paris en
économie je trouve que c'est très cher
surtout lorsque c'est pour des raisons
médicales parce que elle n'arrive pas à
se soigner en Guyane ben il faut prendre
l'avion et il faut payer le billet voilà
Monsieur le Ministre ces deux questions
je vais pas être langue puisque madame
la Présidente a demandé d'être concise
merci
présidente merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
évoquer en fait finalement la difficulté
récurrente de notre tissu économique et
et notamment celle de nots TPE PME en
manque de trésorerie et entravé par les
de paiement ou encore le manque de
diversification de capitaux car il nous
faut tout de même extraire notre
réflexion les grands groupes présents
sur nos territoires et qui tue très
souvent la concurrence à force de
situation monopolistique et cela
participe d'autant plus à la fragilité
de notre tissu économique je
souhaiterais prendre pour exemple
l'entreprise Civa que nous avons vu la
semaine dernière donc cette start-up qui
finalement encline à disparaître à
défaut d'être réellement considéré
malgré les les récompenses malgré les
mérites à louer encore enc une fois la
semaine dernière au moka et quant à son
procédé justement de sécurisation
phytosanitaire de certains fruits dédiés
à l'exportation exportation je vous
rappelle empêché depuis des mesures de
fin 2019 donc lever ses freins
permettrait le développement de
nombreuses TPE PME et donc de favoriser
bien sûr la création d'emplois et voir
peut-être l'exportation de biens et de
services dans les pays de la zone et
finalement finalement et bien participer
au rayonnement de la France dans notre
bassin régional donc monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple la
mission est-ce qu'on la lance quand
est-ce qu'on pourra espérer avoir des
résultats et et finalement comment
compte-on agir pour nous aider à
solidifier notre tissu
économique d'accord ok merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues monsieur le
ministre j'ai deux questions la première
c'est concernant l'incé à Mayot nous
avons bien sûr une population qui
accroit euh très très forte et que
aujourd'hui beaucoup de communes sont en
train de prendre des délibérations pour
pour demander à ce que l'État prenne la
compétence scolaire parce que vous savez
quand on construit des écoles et c'est
ce qui s'est passe à Mayotte à chaque
fois il y a un budget de fonctionnement
qui doit aller avec sauf que comme les
données remontent à 2017 on ne sait plus
et les communes aujourd'hui à chaque
fois sont en difficulté la chambre
rgénale de comptte à chaque fois
intervient que nous gérons mal nos
collectivités alors que nous avons une
population qui n'est pas prise en compte
dans le calcul de la DGF parce que on ne
connaît pas la deuxème question monsieur
le ministre moi je je propose à ce que
dans les mesures du sium qu'on puisse
rajouter un tableau de bilan et de suivi
des mesures de sium une colonne qui soit
rajoutée avec les répercussion
budgétaire c'est-à-dire que moi je vois
dans les mesures SIOM on dit que ça a
été réalisé ça va se faire mais ce
serait bien que à côté nous ayons au
moins le budget qui soit inscrit une
colonne dédiée aux réflections
budgétairees de ce que nous faisons
comme ça au moins les choses sont
claires
merci merci chers collègues donc je vais
laisser la parole à Monsieur le Ministre
avant de poursuivre avec une deuxième
salve de questions merci madame la
Présidente euh madame la sénatrice pour
les contrôles ça me permet d'aborder la
question de la sécurité je pouvais pas
êre sur tous les claviers bon la Guyane
c'estement sujet de sécurité vous le
savez comme moi nous sommes en aition au
Sénat devant les parlementaires on doit
la vérité jamais on a récupéré autant de
cocaïne à l'aéroport du
Cayenne on est à près d'une
tonne le ministre kaznab que j'ai vu il
a midi m'a informé qu'il irait en Guane
en janvier j'essaierai de caler mon
agenda avec le sien
j'entends que ce que nous demandons
force de l'ordre est difficile mais si
jamais on lâche la bride à l'heure
actuelle on ne tiendra plus rien
donc il y a des accords de coopération
que l'on essaie de resserrer avec les
pays qui sont des pays de passage vous
savez tous mieux que moi comment les
choses se passent avec le Brésil en
particulier une immigration qui vient de
la libie Maroc on connait les grandes
voies maintenant ça passe par là et euh
cet exercice est indispensable vous
parlez d'un scanner j'ai noté c'est une
très bonne idée naturellement j'en
parlerai avec Géral d'armanin et sachez
que là on est obligé de continuer et
d'élargir et on a un autre sujet sur les
ports on va devoir prendre les
initiatives dans les prochaines
semaines mais je vais vous dire quelque
chose regardez ce qui se passe en
Belgique regardez ce qui se passe en
Hollande il y a des mesures très
difficiles très restrictives qui
viennent d'être prises et qui ont permis
de resserrer les maillages et donc
maintenant ce sont même des grands ports
hexagonaux j'ai bien dit hexagonaux qui
sont l'objet d'augmentation de trafic
très sensible donc on mènera un combat
total une attention merci d'avoir eu
cette attention pour les personnels euh
et sur le lien carcéral et donc sur la
politique judiciaire de continuité
naturellement avec la politique
judiciaire et j'ai bien pris le point et
croyez bien que je verrai ça avec du P
morti scanner c'est une bonne idée on va
voir comment on peut faire de
même la présidente parla également vous
sa qu'il a des chiens que capacités
absolument formidable donc voilà il a
fallu dans un premier temps cette mesure
conservatoire nous continons ce chemin
madame la sénatrice votre attention sur
les entreprises j'ai la même vous avez
compris que moi une de mes des points
majeurs c'est de le donner plus
d'autonomie au territoire et on soit
capable de moin apporter faut que
quelque part de d'accélérer la la
production locale vous savez ma présence
à la Réunion la semaine dernière pour
réunion qui viennent de baptiser 16e
capital frenchtech de France je suis
très fier très heureux il y avait
d'ailleurs des des très belles
start-up regarde le sénateur Andr Loir
et savez que le réseau reméi et par
exemple il est suivi de la Réunion avec
des une petite start-up qui a été
capable de faire un balisage absolument
exceptionnel oui il y a des problèmes de
de trésorerie oui oui problme de délai
de paiement parce que les collectivités
souvent sont très en retard l'État est
très en retard au travers ses
hôpitaux on a des fois des centaines de
millions d'euros je crois que si je
cumule tout c'est 7 ou 800 millions
d'euros de retard que nous avons sur les
hôpitaux mais dans l'Hexagone on a aussi
la même chose on a mis des règles je
vois d'ailleurs le patron de BPI France
cet après-midi parce que je sais que
c'est pas le bon maillon on a un maillon
intermédiaire que l'on cherche et en
tout cas je suis parfaitement sensible à
cette question là parce qu'une fois de
plus elle est totalement présente aussi
dans l'Hexagone et ce maillon manquant
re la startup pour laquelle on arrive à
trouver un accompagnement d'ailleurs
avec la dgom qui est représent ici par
sa directrice des politiques publiques
j'étais d'ailleurs présent avecelle la
station F lorsqu'il y a eu le la
présentation d'ensemble des startup on
va aller plus loin en 2024 et pour cet
accompagnement des entreprises après sur
la trésorerie faut qu'on discute aussi
avec les régions une compéten économique
vous le savez qui sont capables avec
l'état de mettre en place des outils qui
permettent d'aider juste au financement
en tout cas vous avez raison d'attirer
mon attention là-dessus surtout que nous
vivons un moment au moins de plateau
économique voir quelque part de sujet de
croissance mais l'éclosion de start-up
au bout d'une année 2 années 3 années et
les petites entreprises c'est un vrai
sujet qui toutement dans ma tête et
merci de d'y veiller on reviendra vers
vous pas avoir tout cerné depuis le
début mais en 4 mois et demi déjà je
crois qu' beaucoup de questions qui ont
été abordées mais celle-ci fait partie
des des questions absolument
essentielles euh sur la population Maor
je vrais simplement dire déjà au
sénateur
que j'ai demandé au directeur de Linc
parce que j'ai pris cet engagement
devant vous et je vous donnerai les
éléments dès je les aurai je devrais les
recevoir aujourd'hui j'espère parce que
comme nous sommes ensemble demain mais
si je pas demain je les donnerai la
semaine prochaine il m'a été dit l'autre
jour ce que nous sommes vu je dis devant
également le sénateur tan
que la population de référence pour le
calcul des dotations financières pour
Mayotte était 260000 habitants ça m'a
été dit
ainsi l'INC et le ministère de ver me
disent que ça n'est pas le cas donc j'ai
demandé un écrit pour vérifier que le
décompte est un autre décompte que celui
qui a été donné ça me paraît important
au nom de la transparence entre nous et
hier après-midi j'ai vu le directeur
général de l'UNC nous allons nous avons
défini un C nombre de règles pour mieux
appréhender j'aurais besoin de vous
parce que on va dire les choses très
simplement il y a des les quartiers dans
lesquels nous sommes pas rentrés et
comment on fait et donc les les agents
ont aussi quelque part la volonté je le
comprends d'être accompagné par des des
personnels municipaux pour qu'on puisse
faire des comptes le plus précis donc je
me permet de dire en lien avec votre
question vous m'avez pas de la
compétence scolaire alors je crois qu'on
l'exerce déjà quand même implicitement
je rappelle que pour maot c'est 130
million d'euros par an sur les écoles
sur les fameux CCT on finance
tout
donc on va mettre au maotte dans le CCT
863 millions sur les années 2024 2027
donc on est là je crois pour le
périscolaire hein vous savez qu'on a
réussi à sauver ce financement des
activités périscolaires auteur de 5
million d'euros en tout cas on aur
l'occasion d'échanger ensemble s'il y a
des des sujets et des coins comme on dit
sur lesquel nons évidemment pas ét en
capacité de répondre j'ai bien pris le
point également sur sur le le tableau
d'évolution du Stum vous avez pu voir
qu' AC un peu d'exigence quelles étaient
les mesures nonont pas achevé mais qui
fonctionnaient he parce que il y a eu un
amendement de précision n'est-ce pas
madame la sénatrice que vous a entendu
et oui c'est une bonne idée de dire
combien ça
coûte je crois que c'est une bonne idée
de transparence en tout cas je je
lapporterai
OK et sur les billets d'avion j'ai pas
répondu ceusez-moi je ne voulais pas
excusez-moi pardonnez-moi j'ais noté
plusieurs choses madame
la première chose dans le cadre de la
continuité
territoriale je porte la connaissance
pour tous les ultrarins vous savez ça
par cœur mais pour ceux qui sont pas
ultramarin je vous rappelle qu'il a un
bel outil que connaî bien le ministre
dururel c'est la continuité territoriale
qui permet de prendre en charge une
partie des billets d'avion pour 2024
nous augmentons de 23 millions d'euros
la dotation c'est qu'on passe de 70 à 93
millions d'euros deuxièmement nous
remontons le ccient familial le cent
familial était de 12000 € pour la prise
en compte il est passé à 18000 € 50 %
d'augmentation ça veut dire que au
global 77 % 77 % de la population
ultramarine est éligible à cette aide
nous sommes à moins de 3 semaines de
Noël tous les étudiants de première
année du FAC pour on rentrer et on a
même anticipé la mesure la sénatrice
concon m'a beaucoup interpellé là-dessus
je crois ça pas été facile puisque DJ
est représenté je narrête pas de les
remercier là-dessus parce que pour eu ça
é un peu la révolution de palais et on a
mis 13 personnes en plus aux effectifs
2024 pour aider sur ce sujet là deuxème
question vous navez pas dit vous navez
pas parlé de la Corse donc moi j'en
parle on m dit toujours l'aide à la
continué territoriale par rapport à la
Corse est moins élevé c'est vrai mais
vous êtes des parlementaires donc vous
avez une vision globale des chos vous
n'avez pas une vision restreinte si on
regarde globalement les choses faut
regarder aussi toutes les aides fiscales
il y a 4 milliards d'aides fiscales pour
les territoire ultramarin il y a pas 4
milliardes d'aides fiscales en du
proportion du nombre d'habitants pour la
Corse donc moi si je fais la synthèse
d'aide par habitant sur emble des
territoires ultramarins par rapport à la
Corse c'est quand vous voulez j'ai fait
le calcul les territoires ultramarins
sont plutôt mieux
aidés enfin sur le prix des billet oui
c'est trop cher quand il y a pas de
concurrence c'est très cher avec la
guyan ce qui s'est passé cet été avec
Ker guyan qui a déposé le bilan ça é
très compliqué la DSP d'urgence
refonctionne enfin on commence je crois
que depuis la semaine dernière à avoir
un nouveau des liges intérieur qui
décidé de lancer avec Clément bon une
étude multicentrique pour qu'on voit
comment on génère de la concurrence et
comment on a un modèle économique ver je
vous rappelle qu'on a aidé gouvernement
a aidé depuis 3 ans tant aostral que
corsè on a mis 250 million d'euros sur
la table et pour autant les résultats
sont pas complètement merveilleux et
donc enfin son prix du kilomètre
parcouru ça peut être surprenant parce
que c'est Guillaume collaborateur qui
est à côté de moi qui m'a dit alors j'ai
confiance mais toujours vérifie toujours
un petit peu il m'a dit vous savez
billets d'avion kilomè parcouru ça le
fait sourire et mais ça fait partie un
peu d'un match par moment euh il me dit
vous savez c'est moins cher le kilomère
parcouru par rapport au donc entre
l'hexagone et le territoire ultramarin
par rapport à d'autres kilomètres
d'avion parcouru c'est vrai il est moins
cher mais c'est trop cher c'est cher
1200 € c'est très cher je peux pas vous
dire autrement c'est la vérité je suis
même allé sur Internet vérifier voir
comment ça se passe donc on a fait un
énorme effort de continuité territoriale
on a élargi pour les public parce que ça
me permet de dire une chose encore on a
souhaité que pour les sportifs bon
niveau parce que c'est des sujets les
problèmes d'entraînement dans les
territoir ultra sont pas toujours avec
tous les moyens d'entraînement tout ce
qu'il souhaiteraiit on a élargi pour le
monde culturel hein pour les
intervenants culturels on a élargi aussi
pour les causes familiales parler de
maladiie euh il peut y avoir des décès
il peut avoir des enfants malades et on
a même élargi de un à deux adultes donc
les deux parents qui peissent être pris
en charé donc je crois vraiment puis je
vais vous dire très librement c'est qu'
un bon moment ou un autre ça ça se passe
au ministère des outrains si un jour il
y a un cas très particulier et est la
simplicité de nous alerter euh vous
savez quand on a été maire on essaie me
semble-il d'apporter une réponse je peux
pas vous faire des mesures de pé
générale surt je vous mentirai mais je
pense qu'à tout moment on doit être
aussi en capacité de répondre lorsquil y
a une demande qui est
formulée merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
nous allons poursuivre avec trois autres
interventions monsieur Georg
naturel Dominique Théophile et Eveline
Corbière
naminzo merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre euh alors Boni je
vais être assez rapide ma question
peut-être plus d'ordre général c'est sûr
que la Nouvelle-Calédonie est dans une
situation particulière et aujourd'hui
avec un un contexte encore plus
particulier il y a trois ministres qui
sont venus en 15 jours à Néa il y en a
un je crois il prend l'avion ce soir à
l'heure où on parle il do prendre
l'avion le dernier ministre donc on est
effectivement dans une période
particulière de notre histoire mais ma
question dans un ordre
général c'est de savoir comment nos
territoires alors je je pense à mon
collègue de wice futouna qui est là voir
de la poonisie française avec des des
statuts particuliers comment on
s'inscrit dans dans ces échanges avec
avec vous sur les spécificités de notre
territoire parce que souvent on nous
répond ah mais c'est une compétence
transféré donc ça nous regarde pas j'ai
à un moment donné on est quand
même des citoyens français et on
a le on a le devoir de pouvoir échanger
donc ma question est de savoir à quel
entité on doit s'intéresser est-ce que
c'est au ministère de l'autreemère
est-ce que vous parliez de
d'interministériel d'un travail
interministériel c'est vrai que parfois
on a des sujets particulier dans
certains ministères ce qui serait
intéressant et mon prédécesseur l'avait
proposé il y a quelques années je parle
pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie bien sûr
d'avoir un interlocuteur peut-être sur
des territoires comme le notre qui ont
des statuts particuliers parce que on a
on a du mal à trouver une réponse pas
souvent à nos
questions ensuite j'avais trois petites
question la première je crois que le
gouvernement de la Nouvelle-Calédonie le
président a été a été autorisé à signer
le contrat de développement hein qui qui
la nouvelle génération qui va aller sur
5 ans les les autres collectivités
provinciales et communales sont pas
encore fait il y a eu effectivement je
l'ai dit je l'ai dit dernièrement à une
de nos réunions il y a eu du des
modifications dans la dans la procédure
c'està-dire qu'on va fonctionner sous
forme d'appel à projet c'est une c'est
une manière de fonctionner qui ce qui se
généralise mais en tout cas c'est
parfois ça met en difficulté certaines
collectivités je pense aux petites
communes en particulier donc il y a un
problème d'ingénierie à amener à ces
collectivités là et je crois qu'il
faudra qu'on soit vigilant hein dans la
mise en œuvre des futurs contrats de
développement sinon on va se retrouver
dans 4 5 ans en se disant ben comme je
l'ai entendu encore cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle Ben l'outremè et consomme
pas les crédits qu'on leur a à louer
donc ça je veux pas entendre ça il faut
vraiment qu'on se donne les moyens pour
que nos collectivités puissent répondre
norm le les deux deux autres points
rapidement mais ça en comme je fais
partie comme mon collègue de droite de
la commission aménagement du territoire
et développement durable le changement
climatique est un sujet je pense qui qui
est essentiel dans dans le cadre de nos
politiques publiques en tout cas je suis
très sensibilisé à ce dossier
effectivement je voudrais voir comment
euh des dispositifs hein qui vont être
appliqués au niveau national au niveau
régional voire au niveau des département
du trumè on peut travailler sur la
manière effectivement d'accompagner la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour traiter ces
dossiers- là et puis le dernier on vient
vous venez d'en parler c'est la
continuité territoriale alors je vais
peut-être parler à la place de mon
collègue ex-maire de
Lifou la qutitité territoriale en
Nouvelle-Calédonie elle a aussi elle a
aussi son importance en intérieur on a
on a effectivement des liaisons comme en
polonisée française du reste hein sur
sur nos îles et c'est à savoir comment
l'État peut accompagner que ce soit la
polonisie française ou la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour aider nos
populations effectivement on parlait du
prix du billet mais je crois que c'est
le même prix du Bayer pour pour aller de
né à lififou hein c'est pas loin donc il
y a besoin d'accompagner no population
voilà monsieur le ministre mes questions
rapidement
oui
bon une remarque une suggestion et une
question rapidement moins d'une minute
je sais que c'est un ministère très
difficile puisque vous êtes à plus de 80
% en interministériel et donc il faut
gagner vos arbitrages ce qu'on dit et
donc donc il y a un sujet
qui qui est très important pour nous
aujourd'hui qui tranche un peu avec les
autres sujets du quotidien c'est
l'approche des Jeux
Olympiques en France et j'aimerais
savoir puisque nous sommes un peu très
silencieux
le ministère des autres maères sur la
question d'autant plus que vous
connaissez le proid des autres mèes sur
le sport national donc ce que j'aurais
aimé savoir est-ce que vous avez
travaillé avec la ministre ministre des
Sports sur un plan il y a eu des plans
il y a eu des planans canir il y a eu
d'autres plans euh à l'approche de cet
événement puisque nous sommes bien dans
ce cadre làà et il y a eu un rapport que
la ministre la première ministre a
souhaité la ministre des sport sera
probablement selon son calendrier euh
aux Antilles au mois de janvier est-ce
que vous serez du voyage et est-ce qu'il
y aura aussi une annonce à l'approche de
ces élections deuxème d'autant plus que
il y a un gros problème d'équipement aux
Antilles en tout cas aux Antilles dans
tous les territoires
d'outrem et la la suggestion serait
est-ce que nous pourrions je dire
considérer euh une enveloppe
exceptionnelle dans votre ministère
s'agissant des aides au SP aux
équipements sportifs et aux
associations
madame monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente vous avez évoqué en
introduction la question de la vie chère
j'aimerais y revenir parceque comme vous
le vous l'avez dit aussi Monsieur le
Ministre les solutions doivent être
multiples parce que quand on parle de la
vie chère il n'y a pas seulement les
prix à la consommation il y a l'ensemble
je pense notamment au logement on nous
annonce des augmentations de loyers dans
un contexte d'inflation et euh c'est un
vrai sujet aussi pour pour nous à la
Réunion et et souvent lorsqu'on évoque
la question du logement on revient sur
la question du coût de construction de
production de logement qui est
exorbitant pour nous en
outreem vous aviez évoqué les normes RUP
et les normes CE c'est une avancée
euh et cependant je pense que nous ne
pouvons pas en rester à là je crois que
il y a un une vraie coopération
régionale à mettre en place il faut
vraiment que le gouvernement accompagne
les territoires ultramarins pour qu'il y
ait des coopérations régionales qui
s'organisent dans les bassins de vie
avec les pays voisins et que ces normes
rupes seront les bienvenus mais encore
faut-il préparer le terrain et je pense
notamment à la position euh que vous
prendrez quant à la création d'une
compagnie régionale maritime euh pour
justement en finir avec le transit via
l'Hexagone quand il s'agit de circuit
euh de production euh et euh de de
transformation de produits notamment de
produits
alimentaires parce que euh la crise
covid la crise de la guerre en Ukraine t
tous ces sujets nous amènent à à à être
convaincu que la solution c'est
l'économie circulaire que il faut
arriver à produire et à consommer dans
un bassin de vie et que il nous faut
aussi baisser l'empreinte carbone parce
que transiter depuis l'océan Indien
passer par l'Hexagone pour revenir dans
les euh la grande distribution
localement c'est un c'est un schéma
absurde et euh et et pour moi la
solution c'est la compagnie régionale
maritime où en êtes-vous comment vous
situez-vous par rapport à ce à ce sujet
est-il prévu que vous accompagnez les
territoires dans ces démarches de
coopération et ma deuxième question
concerne vous le savez à la Réunion on a
ce problème de déplacement qui bloque
notre économie locale enfin qui est
vraiment
pénalisant et puisque nous avons fait
les les les politiques précédentes ont
fait le choix du tout automobile et
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin d'être
accompagné également pour un projet
paril où en est-on de la dotation
ferroviaire pour lillele et est-ce que
vous avez un calendrier à nous donner
merci bien beaucoup de questions madame
la Présidente je vais si j'oublie
quelque chose la simplicité de de me
reprendre je répondra avec plaisir euh
tout d'abord nouvelle C
donie non ne vous oublie pas vous savez
je suis déjà venu vous voir Gérald
d'manin je crois fait un boulot
considérable avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes il y a eu plus de 12 mois de
rencontres de concertation j'ai
d'ailleurs participer à C nombre de ces
concertations quand j'étais venu à Na
mais également à beauau et à l'Élysée
l'objectif du départ ça me permet de
parler de réformes institutionnelle il y
a évolution du corps électoral je crois
d'ailleurs savoir que conseil l'État en
ce moment même travaille sur ce sujet
euh savoir si on passe par les LO
organique savoir si c'est une réforme
constitutionnelle mais on sera
éclairirer là-dessus rapidement euh la
deuxième chose c'était une réforme aussi
plus large qui était qui était visée
mais il fallait que tout le monde soit
autour de la table vous savez que il y a
quelques jours malheureusement ça n'a
pas été possible euh mais pour vous dire
que la porte d'entrée bien sûr c'est les
très bien moi je travaille main dans la
main avec Géral d'manin et et j'ai
promis parce qu'une demande m'a été
faite par par W et Futuna les
Polynésiens également m'ont fait la
demande le sium ne concerne pas vos
trois
territoires donc je réfléchis on
trouvera un temps qui vous sera réservé
pris l'engagement l'autre jour parce que
tout ne s'arrête pas non plusis à la
réforme institutionnelle il y a d'autres
questions qui sont très importantes très
prignantes et si vous voulez bien je
serai votre porte d'entrée pour ensuite
naturellement m'ouvrir sur sur tous mes
collègues tout en sachant que pour la
nouvelle cée de
voyez pas plus tard que hier je voyais
une des ambassadrices de la région parce
qu'il faut ça vaut d'ailleurs une
réponse pour la sénatrice qui m'a tout à
l'heure posé la question sur le
rayonnement régional j'aurais dû dire
dans mon mot de présentation qu'il y a
une dimension qu'il faut que nous
travaillons absolument c'est les
Antilles le environnement raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs j'étais à Dubaï pour
la où j'ai lancé une initiative
internationale sur les
sargas l'Indien où on doit discuter par
définition avec Maurice et j'ai vu que
c'était pas complètement fluide avec
Madagascar euh voyez par exemple pour
l'eau à Mayotte au départ je me suis dit
j'ai peut-être aussi en complément
acheter de l'eau à Maurice bah c'est pas
les mêmes normes compliqué quand même
donc je mets des bateaux pendant 28
jours sur la mer alors que j'ai une eau
qui est fabriquée qui est à côté mais il
y a des normes qui sont un peu
différentes donc voez tout ça est
parfaitement dans dans ma tête madame la
sénatrice vous dire aussi pour continuer
bien sûr sur la nouvelle conique sur les
sujets li au changement climatique votre
collègue député du noyer ma sensible il
y a un amendement que j'ai retenu en 493
j'aur d'ailleurs dire que il y a parité
de traitement entre guillemets entre
l'Assemblée et le Sénat sur
l'atterrissage du 493 j'ai veillé à ce
que dans un bicamérisme
respecté la répartition de ce que nous
avons pu Saver matin en arbitrage
budgétaire etvec Guillaume vaille soit
réparti entre les parlementaires de
façon équilibrée et donc il y a une
réponse qui est apporté dans le
budget sur la question que vous me posez
enfin sur les sur les
non mais les sénateurs sont pas oubliés
en plus il y a un excellent avocat
également sénateur et enfin sur la
continuité territoriale alors là j'ai en
revanche une réponse qui moins facile à
entendre mais c'est vrai que mais vous
êtes des pays sur lequel vous avez aussi
la capacité de conduire des politiques
ouis ça coûte deargent c'est bien après
ce sont des choix politiques on peut pas
tout faire donc les collectivités
peuvent aussi décider parce que c'est
vrai que l'isolement fait les moyens de
transport sont des sujets sur lesquel on
est présent pour autant je rappelle que
la nouvelle ku n'est pas oubliée il y a
eu un accord qui a été passé suite
justement aux accord des 88 il y a une
dotation qui est donnée chaque année
j'ai répondu d'ailleurs un député
polynésien à l'Assemblée sur cette
question là l'autre jour parce que la
dotation par habitant m'était demandé
donc le chiffre est tout à fait
atteignable et je crois que c'est un un
chiffre qui est assez conséquent nous
sommes là on continuera de l'être et
d'ailleurs le président Mapou la
nouvelle cahé d'onie s'est vu quand même
octroyer 37 millions d'euros très
précisément parce que c'est'est passé
chez moi à un moment en deux fois
en en réponse miroire à des réformes
aussi qui doivent être faites au niveau
de de la Nouvelle Calédonie enfin sur
sur le nickel vous savez que bonau le ma
également est allé là-bas on a une
sitation qui est compliquée depuis
longtemps c'est pas la peine qu'on se
raconte l'histoire entre nous on y
veille de façon je crois très attentive
mais on peut pas faire gouvernement le
boulot la place des entreprises on a
aussi des sujets les permis miniier les
permis d'extraire les permis d'exporter
c'est le le gouvernement calédonien qui
ne veut pas qu'on exporte c'est quand
même dommage au moment où l'énergie
électrique prend toute sa dimension au
moment où on a besoin de batterie
toujours plus nombreuses que on AER
chercher des batteries qui vont faire
20000 km sur les mers alors qu'elle
pourrait les faire pas très loin il peut
y avoir des des usines on peut trouver
des des des factories avec les
territoires qui sont pas très loin que
soit l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande et
l'Inde aussi qui n'est pas très loin
voilà donc pour ces raisons-là euh enfin
nous serons extrêmement attentifs bien
sûr pour c'est Théophile al je sais
qu'il est extrêmement sensible à toutes
les questions liées au sport il a raison
et qu'il y a un rapport important qui a
été qu'il a écrit dans les CCT les
contrat de condué de transformation il y
a un chiffrage pour les équipements
sportifs qui est de 56 million d'euros
je sais qu'il y a des déficit
d'équipement après j'ai envie de dire
que dans les CCT tout n'est pas
bouclé quand je dis que c'est pas bouclé
c'est comme un contrat planin état
région dans l'Hexagone on négocie entre
l'État et et les et les collectivités
qui veulent porter c'est des projets les
financements en fait ils viennent de
trois endroits ENF ils viennent de deux
endroits ils viennent de l'État au
travers des CCT il peut y avoir des
fléchages mais un CCT ce qui est
important ça me permet de répondre aussi
à une question que vous avez posé madame
la sénatrice moi ce que je souhaite
surtout c'est que les crédit mis sur la
table soit consommé et pour qu'il soit
consommé euh il y a des questions il a
l'ingénierie et je rappelle d'ailleurs
vous avez été quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
poussé les moyens in géerie pour aider
les territoires ultr-amarins passent de
10 millions à 20 millions d'euros en
2024 on double la
mise et au-delà des simples soutiens
qu'on apportera aux collectivités on
aura un pool à main à la main des
préfets qui seront là pour aider les
collectivités que soit les départements
que soit les régions concernées que ce
soit les pays que ce soit les communes
pour aller plus loin donc très
précisément 56 millions d'euros fléchés
sur ces questionsl sur euh amé de la
casttera donc la ministre des Sports on
a travaillé un peu sur la Polynésie avec
les quelques difficultés que chacun peut
comprendre notamment les preuves qui
doit en principe encore avoir lieu
là-bas et on a travaillé également sur
la façon dont on pouvait faire vivre le
sport au travers des jeux olympiques C
nom d'événements qui vont avoir m'
informé d'un déplacement au mois de
janvier j'espère que on aura une
compatibilité d'agenda parce que on n
pas toujours la même compatibilité mais
si cette compatibilité de rendez-vous
naturellement j'iraai avec elle et vous
dire enfin que il y a la ns qui l'
is et puis enfin il y a le FEI on fera
des choix des choix stratégiques c'est
qu'en clair le FEI j'en profite pour
rappeler que en 2024 il par de 110
millions à 120 millions
d'euros en crédit de paiement et qu'
autoriseation son engagement là où il
était à 40 millions d'euros il y a 4
ans 40 million d'euros il a 4 ans 2017
oui et on passe à 120 millions d'euros
donc on aura triplé la mise pas pas
beaucoup de budget où on en est là et en
autorisation d'engagement on augmente de
50 millions en 2024 donc après moi j'ai
eu ce choix je vous dis monsieur
sénateur dans mon territoire sur un
contrat passé avec la région et bien on
avait fléché 40 % d'équipements sportifs
en accord avec les élus c'est aussi la
capacité que l'on a lorsqu'on est élu de
dire je priorise tel ou tel sujet si on
fait toutes les priorités en même temps
on les sort pas mais si on priorise on
sera là en tout cas merci de le rappeler
parce que vous avez certainement vu que
je suis allz l'autre jour à bourge pour
la section outrem cyclisme qui va
pouvoir qui dans un accord avec le CRP
centre valdeoire faire en sorte que des
des champion ultramarin qui soit
entraînés à bourge et qui reviendront
ensuite parce qu'il y a un autre
dispositif je termine parce que je sais
que vous êtes sensible c'est cadre
d'avenir cadre d'avenir qui s'ouvre pour
faire en sorte que l'on permette à des à
des jeunes qui se forment dans
l'Hexagone de repartir le domaine du
sport fera parti ce domain là d'ailleurs
le l'adjoint directeur technique
national de cyclisme est très demandeur
pour être formé dans le territoire et
repartir ensuite en Guadeloupe et
Martinique je trouve c'est une belle
évolution ensuite madame la sénatrice
m'avait interrogé sur la vie chè le
logement
euh et les circuits courts l'économie
circulaire et très sensible vous l'avez
compris la diplomatie régionale et le
développement régionaux pour moi ça fait
partie naturellement des développements
urgents à
réaliser la première chose que je tiens
à vous dire vous l'avez souligné
vous-même la norme Rupe c'est un premier
élément il y a une deuxième chose il y a
un travail où vous savez que dans cette
maison il y a un sénateur qui s'appelle
er Doliger qui était présent il y a
quelques années qui av fait un très gros
boulot sur les normes à la demande de la
première ministre je vais regarder
exactement quelles sont les normes qui
sont complexes et qui rencheriss la vie
au quotidien mais la difficulté c'est
qu'il faut que je passe une fois qu'ell
soit identifié par une loi
d'habilitation du gouvernement par
ordonnance une fois que tout est ciblé
parce qu'on commence à ouvrir une norme
on en ouvre 200 ou 500 et on s'en
sortira jamais et euh il faut que je
prenne quelqu'un au Conseil d'État qui
fasse ce travail là en tout cas je
croyeis bien que ça fait partie de mes
de mes perspectives pour le début
d'année prochaine sur le logement je
l'avais rappelé dans mon introduction
liminire je sais qu'il y a des vra
sujets de logementhitation de logement
inoccupés le fait qu'il y a à la fois
les normes RUP qui vont s'appliquer à la
fois la LBU alors certes victorien Lurel
qui est là c'est ça parfaitement mieux
que moi on revient on revient à un
niveau qui était su de 2013 les députés
me l'ont fait remarquer parce qu'on a eu
des sous-consommations de LBU donc là je
pense qu' on a augmenté de 50 millions
on sera sur une consommation accrue euh
les outils financés par l'ANA en passant
de de 35 à 50 % je rappelle que là les
collectivités territoriales peuvent
abonder
elles peuvent abonder hein ell c'est
tout à fait autorisé donc je crois qu'il
faut aller sur cette voie-là on a
élargissement de compétences d'Action
Logement sur certain territoir qui m'
fait la demande l'économie circulaire
oui madame je je vous suis totalement
euh vous savez lorsque à la Réunion je
vois qu'il y a unité de valorisation de
déchets où on se termine par de la
chaleur et de la Bagas qui de la mégas
je me dis B Dieu tout a été compris et
c'est formidable mais il faut aussi
assurer justement sur les déchets l'eau
l'assainissement sont les vrais
fondamentaux où nous sommes là rappelle
d'ailleurs que nous dans le soutien
d'ingéerie nous finançons le
gouvernement finance ça passe par les
autres mes par exemple SM de Guadeloupe
nous finançons 11 équivalents en
plein des techniciens pour aider les
collectivités donc vous avez je vous
suis une bonne nouvelle vous c'est que
c'est le hum maritime Guadeloupe
Martinique qui va avoir une véritable
boie verte avec des bateau de grande
résilience et que sont des bateaux
propres je pense qu'on devrait boucler
puce que des grands ports les conseil
d'administration des grands ports on
valider que les deux présidents de
région nous accompagnent Guadeloupe et
Martinique et c'est important l'État met
beaucoup d'argent là-dedans et c'est
près de 300 millions d'euros ça veut
dire qu'il y a des bateaux qui n'auront
plus 20000 km à faire et qui passeront
justement jusqu'à Panama par cette voie
verte donc on progresse vous avez je
vous suis totalement et puis sur la TGAP
je l'ai dit j'essaie de me bagarer pour
faire en sorte qu'elle ararrête
d'augmenter parce que je sais qu'elle
est invalidante donc j'ai besoin des
sénateurs de leur voix sage et assuré
alors je vous dis pas que je vais faire
des exonérations parce que j'arriverai
pas oui monsieur le sénateur je vois que
vous me regardez tout d'un coup mais
mais je sais que vous êtes extrêmement
sensible
pardon oui
monsieur
oui
ici au Sénat nombre de
d'amendementser les amendements sur le
l'article 7 TER ici euh j'ai tous les
dispositifs sur la défiscalisation sur
le les meublés sur le tourisme sur la
TGAP nous avons tous euh euh fait voter
euh cette affaire et sur les amendements
logements est-ce que vous comptez les
garder dans la navette
on peut avoir je n'ose pas vous poser la
question extraordinaire en 20 secondes
il règle un truc qu'on a pas réglé en 3
mois c'est formidable mais je vois la V
les pas réponses je devrais partir et
sur les 320 millions que vous avez
annoncé pour l'eau en weel sur 4 ans
j'aimerais savoir quelles sont les
missions et les imputations pour que je
me fasse une idée précise des engagement
et quels sont les dossiers qui seront
les conventions qui seront signées je
drois partir malheureusement mais soyez
pas là Monsieur sénateur quand on n'est
pas là pour défendre un amendement après
c'est compliqué amendement est-ce que
vous comptez les garder monsieur
sénateur les enfants
ai il y a pas mal
de monsieur le ministre vous me
connaissez bien je je ne prends pas des
engagements que je ne tiens pas sur la
défiscalisation pendant que vous marchez
vous savez très bien qu'il y a un énorme
travail qui a été fait avec la FIDOM je
CIS qu'on a fait un atterrissage
intelligent pour permettre à chacun de
s'y retrouver et qu'on a été je crois
très ouvert euh les chauaux électriques
on continuera pour les entreprises les
véhicules les 44 on continuera pour les
entreprises on continuera pas pour le
particulier qui va se faire diffisciser
sa voiture pour parler clairement on
sera là pour le tourisme y compris les
les gites à l'issu d'un
combat pas simple mais que nous avons
réglé monsieur sénateur je tiens à vous
le dire avec berc nous onons fait
entendre votre voix puissante et
redondante mais voilà et euh voilà à
bientôt bon et bon on eff fait je crois
écoutez je pas vous dire que c'est
parfait tant s'en
faut ça me permet de dire un mot je
crois que l'atterrissage a été même
souligné comme assez positif
euh ce qu'il faut c'est fiscale trouver
l'efficience quoi on va pas se raconter
hisire entre nous donc moi tout ce qui
est efficient qui permet de SAU de
l'emploi de le préserver je suis à 1000
% engagé sur tout ça il y a euu quelques
débordements comme on sait très bien
mais Victor Lurel le sait parfaitement
il a apparten à des gouvernements qu' on
fait la même chose donc ça parquitement
donc bref vous vous dire
que par rapport aux question de la
TGAP j'ai totalement conscience du sujet
je vi discutter avec Christophe Béchu
discuter avec Thomas casaznav nous avons
une inter ministérielle là-dessus pour
trouver une solution qu' peut pas
continuer à avoir envoler de la TGAP qui
posera une difficulté peut pas à la fois
avoir le
fardeau de ce élément majeur que sont
l'élimination des déchets la
valorisation derrière et pas trouver une
solution d'accompagnement de là
supprimer complètement c une nouvelle
nich calcul on ouvre et la voix de la
raison me conduit à dire qu'on peut pas
le faire mais j'entends parfaitement
cette préoccupation là euh je reviens 2
secondes donc sur la
signatrice de la Réunion qui m'interrogé
sur le rail et que M interrogé sur les
compagnies régionales les compagnies
régionales je vous rappelle qu'une
région peut si elle le souhaite créer
une compagnie régionale on vous a donné
les compétences ple anée entière il faut
les utiliser en région Centre valdoire
il y a une ligne qui s'appelle salaleb
Luc LAL je parle devant sénateur Loir
qui est géré par une compagnie Privée
qui d'ailleurs gagne de l'argent donc on
peut le faire c'est un rappel également
vous savez madame la sénatrice que la
route nationale du littoral a coûté 1
milillard 250 million d'euros sur lequel
nous avons apporté 85 % de financement
porte la connaissance de tout le monde
pour que la transparence soit de mise
après je sais c très compliqué j'en ai
parlé avec la présidente B la semaine
dernière il y a eu un projet qui a
abandonné malheureusement la continuité
territoriale là où elle est des fois ça
n'est pas la continuité politique et que
des qui été conçuit par les uns soit
décousu par les autres c'est regrettable
en tout cas elle m'a informé qu'il y a
des études qui étaient en cours pour
voir comment on pourraz faire passer des
transports en site propre j'imagine pas
qu'on soit pas présent à un moment ou un
autre lorsque vous aurez une
stabilisation de votre projet mais ça
c'est pas nous qui allons décider pour
les éus locaux et ça je ferai jamais ça
vous savez moi je conserve encore un
tropisme où j'aime bien l'état mais que
l'État reste à sa place qu'il soit là
pour accompagner mais soit là pour pour
décider sinon quelque part un infantil
locou en tout cas moi je ne le ferai
jamais donc vous appartient définir le
projet en Rance une compagnie régionale
si vous voulez faire du transport
régional aucune difficulté vous avez
toute la capacité de le faire ça sonans
problème la loi vous l'autorise donc je
vous insite à le faire et je suis
persuadé que vous saurez sur les
questions écologiques et ça me permet de
dire d'ailleurs que votre territoire a
été le
premier à s'engager dans une politique
extrêmement ambieux d'énergie
renouvelable et et la politique
plannuelle de l'énergie d'ailleurs ayez
tous en tête que teritoir ultramarins
sont en avance par rapport à l'Hexagone
sur la production d'énergie
renouvelable et qu'après on doit être
assez innovant et voyez hier une
réflexion qui était conduite et je
voyais le ministre de l'Environnement et
qui me disait que sur le problème de des
éoliennes notamment et le suet que l'on
a ce sont les Chinois qui sont en train
de fabriquer la plupart des turbines
fait peut-être qu'on s'interroge et ne
pas
laisser certains concurrents qui sont là
pour prendre toutes les partes de marché
comme ils l'ont fait avec les
photovoltaïques tout ce qui demain
contribue
dura et bien avoir une énergie
décarbonée voilà donc ne lâchez pas vos
ambitions je crois qu'on en a beaucoup
en
partage si vous permettez dans le sur le
pour la Réunion donc vous vous me dites
qu'une région doit rivaliser avec des
États tels que la Chine et l'Inde qui
sont en présence qui sont présentes de
façon
importante dans l'océan Indien
nous allons nous allons poursuivre donc
avec viviene mé tan
Mohamed et
Michelou merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé
dans vos propos d'énergie renouvelable
pour la production de l'énergie solaire
je souhaitais vous cessir pour les
installations d'une puissance de 100 kW
crê à 500 kW CR donc c'est c'est donc
des dossiers qui ne passent pas par la
creux mais par un tarif de rachat par
EDF alors à ma connaissance à ce jour ce
dernier n'est pas fixé la filière est
donc en attente de la publication de
l'arrêté
S22 pour revaloriser le tarif de rachat
et lever le seuil des projets à 500 Kow
crê beaucoup de réalisations sont en
attente notamment à la réunion sur les
sites publics sur les grandes toitures
comme les écoles les collèges alors
pourriez-vous nous assurer que cet
arrêté soit rapidement mise en œuvre
parce que je pense qu'on a on a le
soleil donc l'énergie solaire je pense
qu'on pourrait quand même être les bons
élèves et puis bon je vais quand même
vous remercier de vous être préoccupé le
dossier de la TGAP qui me tient à cœur
et c'est vrai que bon vous avez dit
qu'on é n'était pas les mauvais élèves
c'est vrai on voudrait être les bons
élèves mais bon il faut nous accompagner
je pense que cette TGAP il faudra la
réformer pour les pour l'utremire merci
Monsieur le
Ministre merci beaucoup madame la la
présidente monsieur le le
ministre en complément de ce que sa a
dit tout à l'heure j'aimerais revenir
sur trois trois points rapidement
insister sur le travail en
interministériel tous les sujets se
recoupent sont interdépendants en plus
quand on sait que
90 % des crédits outre ma sont gérés par
les autres ministère euh c'est cette
gestion en interministériel est est plus
que que nécessaire moi ce que je
souhaitaer demander c'est que avant
l'arbitrage est-ce qu'il y a euh moyen
euh d'écouter par exemple les
parlementaires
euh je le dis parce que nous sommes
allés au
kedersé cette semaine avec avec Saïd et
effectivement tous les sujets à maot
sont sont liés même quand on parle euh
des sujets de de de l'étranger euh par
contre
euh les décisions sont prises sans
forcément euh que les les parlementaires
a été a été entendu est-ce qu'au niveau
de du ministre min des outrumires euh il
pourrait être organisé une étape avant
l'arbitrage pour que nous puissions
plaider euh ces dossiers en
interministériel le le deuxième sujet
c'est sur la
DGCCRF nous pourrons nous pourrions
voter tous les dispositifs possibles et
imaginables à notre maire s'il n'y a pas
de contrôle suffisant ça sert à rien
euh nous avons voté l'augmentation euh
de des membres de de de la DGCCRF euh ça
serait bien monsieur le ministre je sais
que vous vous pouvez vous allez monter
au créneau sur le dossier que euh en
outre maire on ne soit pas oublié la vie
chè euh les les les la chérité des
billets d'avion les normes tout ça
mérite un contrôle accru un contrôle
supplémentaire et et il n'y a que la
DGCCRF qui qui qui peut qui peut
intervenir c'est quand même c'est quand
même quelque chose que même sur les
matériaux qui sont produits localement
et bien les prix s'envent euh donc le le
contrôle est vraiment est vraiment
important et puis dernier point euh sur
les violences à mayillotte désolé j'en
parle tout le temps euh mais si on ne
trouve pas de solution tous les autres
sujets ne valent pas la peine d'être
d'être discuté et cette violence elle
est commise par une bande de jeunes euh
l'automaticité euh requiert qu'on fasse
appel aux forces de l'ordre et encore
encore aux forces de l'ordre mais c'est
pas suffisant on le sait c'est pas
suffisant euh non seulement euh je je
plaide pour un changement de de doctrine
c'est pas ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
évident mais nous savons qu'à Mayotte
euh des milliers de jeunes sont passés
sous le radar de la formation et de
l'encadrement pendant des années et des
années euh on on récupère ça aujourd'hui
si si je puis dire mais mais euh comment
comment faire pour rattraper euh tout ce
qui n'a pas été fait le le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald darmana avait parlé à
un moment d'un encadrement qui serait
inspiré par ce qui se fait au SMMA euh
parce que contrairement aux idées reçues
beaucoup de ces jeunes sont de
nationalité française ce ne sont pas des
étrangers ils ont des cartes ils ont des
des pièces d'identité euh françaises
donc euh chaque année c'est plus de 5000
jeunes qui sortent du circuit euh de
formation et du circuit scolaire pour
lesquel il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
grand-chose donc que faire je sais que
la la question est est compliquée mais
mais c'est plus une invitation à ce que
nous puissions en discuter pour trouver
euh pour trouver des des des solutions
et notamment celle qui seraiit euh
inspirée par ce qui se fait au au SM au
SMMA c'est-à-dire l'encadrement euh des
des militaires et puis dans l'immédiat
monsieur le ministre je pense qu'il y a
lieu euh vraiment de de de changer la la
politique pénale euh qui se qui ACC
court alors je je je je le demanderai
auprès du du du garde des saau mais dans
dans ces bandes de jeunes
euh il y a une aide une assistance des
familles pour les nourrir pour les
préparer pour qu'ils ayent casser
et il n'y a pas de poursuite pour ces
gens alors qu'il y a au moins complicité
par aide et et et assistance
euh là il y a pas besoin de légiférer le
code pénal est là le code de procédure
pénale est là mais il est nécessaire si
on veut avoir une chance de de de de
surmonter ce ce chaos que une une
politique pénale change il faudrait pas
que les magistrats n'en fassent qu'à
leur tête que le
n'en face qu'à sa tête et et je peux
vous assurer que la poursuite des
parents notamment quand ils ont des
cartes de séjour avec la menace que la
la carte de séjour est est en péril mais
je peux vous garantir que le lundemain
tout le monde se met à carreau
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre j'aurais juste tris
point évoquer et donc comme vous le
savez l'actualité àou founa n'est pas
fameuse avec cette histoire de la banque
la BWF et toutes les tensions qui qui en
sont relative
euh je demanderaiis je solliciterai
l'action de l'État l'intervention de
l'État auprès de la BNP Paribas puisque
c'est la BWF est une filiale de la B P
pariva
euh actuellement il est très difficile
de de trouver un terrain d'entente entre
euh les bloqueurs qui sont bien sûr les
entrepreneurs le milieu entrepreneurial
et le BTP également les particuliers
puisque tout le monde est victime de des
agissements de la BWF et notamment de la
réaction de directeur général de la BNP
Paribas à nin euh ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui euh enfin en tout cas ce
matin c'était la fin de la journée île
morte euh de walis et Futuna cela veut
dire que depuis la semaine dernière euh
tout était bloqué la banque était bloqué
l'Assemblée territoriale elle-même
elle-même qui devait ouvrir la session
de fin d'année jeudi jeudi matin n'a pas
pu euh procéder à cette session à cette
ouverture de la session aujourd'hui ça
s'est empiré puisque les tous les
commerçants ont été solidaires puisque
tout le monde est un peu victime de des
clôtures abusives des comptes que ça
soit les entrepreneurs ou les
particuliers commerçant
euh plus personne ne comprend les
raisons pour les qui motiv les
agissements de la de la banque aussi
bien de la BWF et bien sûr le
cautionnement de la BNP Paribas de N
donc je solliciterai monsieur le
ministre l'intervention ferme et
conséquente de
l'État par votre
intermédiaire pour essayer de trouver
une solution et sortir un peu de cette
situation qui est très difficile
actuellement
euh le deuxème point que je voulais
évoquer euh justement ça je rejoint un
peu la cheté de la vie inutile de dire
que wftuna bien sûr est le certainement
le plus mal placé
euh que ça soit au niveau distance par
rapport à Paris et donc de sur croix au
niveau des coûts des transports de la
desserte maritime de la desserte
aérienne tout est relatif euh donc euh
je solliciterai monsieur le ministre euh
que par rapport à cette à ces situations
monopolistiques que ça soit euh
l'énergie
heinwf que ça soit Aircalin pour la
desserte
aérienne le sou pe pour la desserte
maritime et la BWF bien sûr que je
venais de
d'évoquer toutes
ces situations monopolistiqu sont là
bien sûr pour motiver aider à la chireté
de la vie et j'avais déjà sollicité au
Sénat au sein de
l'hémicycle l'élargissement de la de la
loi de l'aide au au fret
jusqu'à je demanderaiis également aussi
monsieur le ministre au passage à ce que
un service un vrai service d'état de
contrôle des prix soit mis en place à
puisque ne bénéficiant que d'un
observatoire des prix on ne peut pas
faire
grandchose à part observer les prix bien
sûr entre guillemet 3è point que je
voulais évoquer avec vous puisque vous
l'avez dit à demi-mot vers la fin de
votre discours c'est
l'évolution statutaire institutionnel de
concernant wftoun comme vous le savez et
comme je le répète depuis de nombreux
mois voire des
années j'ai un peu honte de de parler de
cette situation par rapport à WFT
puisqu'on est la seule collectivité dont
l'exécutif est encore depuis 2003 entre
les mains du représentant de l'État qu
le préfet euh donc j'en ai parlé à
Stéphane Artano hein avec Micheline qui
était avec le bureau de la délégation
des outremures qu'il fallait qu'on fasse
que je voulais m'appuyer un peu sur
l'élan de la délégation des outremèes
pour trouver un point d'appui de manière
à ce qu'on puisse euh organiser ou alors
mettre en place c'est un groupe de
travail de manière à travailler
sérieusement euh sur ce dossier
qui importe énormément à la population
de wftuna ainsi qu'à ses dirigeants
puisque aujourd'hui on on a un créneau
qui est favorable au niveau du
gouvernement pour qu'on puisse procéder
à cela et donc aujourd'hui il serait
opportun pour wftuna de pouvoir euh
récupérer
l'exécutif à son assemblée territoriale
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci chers
collègues alors nous allons poursuivre
puisque nous sommes nous arrivons
presque au terme de de l'audition je
laisserai la parole à notre collègue
Jean-Gérard Paumier puis caerine Cancon
et enfin je terminerai cette salve de
question merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre un constant forme
de satisfaitite et une question le
constat d'abord ben j'ai perçu avec
satisfaction dans vos de ministre que
vous n'avez pas oublier l'él local que
vous avez été c'est pas le cas de tous
les ministres en mettant l'accent sur la
proximité l'écoute et l'action concrète
c'est fondamental car il y a une attente
très forte de moins de verticalité et de
plus de coconstruction dans l'action de
l'État avec les élus des outremèes et
même au-delà ma question depuis un mois
que j'ai intégré cette délégation aux
outremè je mesure ma méconnaissance
d'élus local hexagonal du valde Loire
des questions des Outremers et leur
stratégique pour notre pays monsieur le
ministre qu'envisagez-vous comme action
pour sensibiliser davantage nos
collectivités locales et nos concitoyens
de l'Hexagone aux questions des outr mes
merci merci bonjour madame la Présidente
bonjour monsieur le ministre chers
collègues je vais être très brève je
crois que le Parlement nous apprend à
faire
synthétique d'abord vous dire que je
suis toujours dans un esprit de
construction c'est comme ça que je vois
la vie politique les les l'ambiance
hyperpiticienne a toujours considérer
que quand on ne fait pas partie de
l'autre camp rien n'est bon c'est pas
mon style et je tiens pour preuve les
efforts qui ont été faits par le
ministère par l'État concernant la
continuité territoriale le Sénat a tenu
la plume nous avons rendu un un rapport
très dense très très sur des questions
très complexes et vous avez abouti à
aujourd'hui tenir compte de nos
préconisations et je voulais vous dire
bravo il y a encore des marge de
manœuvre il y a encore à progresser par
exemple dans le futur budget de l'an
prochain mais déjà on on a mené un peu
la révolution en matière de continuité
territoriale la deuxième chose que je
voulais vous demander là cette fois
c'est de voir dans quelle mesure on
pourrait muscler un peu les moyens de
l'incer vous savez on est des
territoires fragiles où les choses
changent tout le temps il faudrait tout
simplement que nos territoires soient
mis sous monitoring permanent et pour
cela l'in a besoin de moyens
supplémentaires pour déclencher très
rapidement des études les mettre à jour
dans des délais qui soient raisonnable
et qu'on puisse à tout moment pouvoir
influencer une politique publique
influencer une tendance grâce à des
chiffres à jour alors l'INC fait tous
les moyens possibles avec les moyens
qu'ils ont mais je pense que cela
méritait d'être musclé pour avoir un
outil qui soit encore plus up to date
qu'aujourd'hui
merci merci donc je clôturerai cette
série de
questions l'article 252 de la loi dite
3DS prévoit la remise d'un rapport au
Parlement sur l'organisation de la santé
et de la sécurité du de la sécurité
sociale à
saint-bartélémé ce rapport aurait dû
être rendu depuis juillet 2022 euh je ne
cesse de de le de le réclamer sa
publication a été annoncée plusieurs
fois par et vos services m'assure qu'il
est prêt donc j'aurais aimé savoir si
vous pouvez m'annoncer une date
de de présentation de transmission au
Parlement euh et j'aurais une question
encore un peu plus large concernant la
la délégation serait-il
serait-il possible de nous préciser quel
est le calendrier des travaux des deux
experts chargés de faire des
propositions sur le projet d'évolution
institutionnelle bien merci de la
richesse des
questions et merci merci de la qualité
de cette audition madame la sénatrice my
je sais votre attention attachement sur
le sujet de la TGAP vous m'avez
convaincu très largement je fais tout ce
que je peux parce que je sais qu'il y a
pas de modèle économique viable et comme
l'a dit le sénateur Jean-Gérard
Pomier j'ai monté moi-même dans ma
circonscription une traitement d'ordeur
ménagère je sais ce que ça coûte donc je
sais qu'on peut pas y arriver voilà donc
on va tout faire et voilà je va essayer
de faire œuvre de de conviction et pour
le arrêtés de de rachat de tarif de
rachat EDF mon équipe l'a noté on va
revenir vers vous je cherge Guillaume
vaille de me préparer le petit courrier
de réponse qui va bien je serai
extrêmement
attentif monsieur sénateur
tan
DGCCRF plus 10 effectifs en 2024 c'est
pas assez c'est le début d'un
chemin économie souterraine les monopole
et tout ce qui contribue à créer du
désordre croyez bien que vous vrais pour
votre parfaite information comme vous le
savez j'ai fait 15 ans de commission de
finances à l'Assemblée donc plutôt
attaché à ce que on fasse les choses
correctement je serai avec vous pour
demander encore des moyens
complémentaires et en tout cas nous
prenons le bon chemin le bculier qualité
prix je crois que c'est quelque chose
qui est essentiel d'ailleurs j' vais
demander au préfet d'élargir son
assiette sur les
violences on aura l'occasion de se
reparler parce c'est un sujet que vous
avez évoqué l'autre jour sur la doctrine
bon le niveau de violence est
extrêmement important je pense que la
réponse que nous avons apporté dans
l'urgence avec Gérald l'ARM la semaine
dernière juste après mon appel 20
minutes après il annoncé un 7e escadron
de mobile qui est arrivé hier à Mayotte
moi je ne peux pas laisser les forces de
l'ordre blesser je ne peux pas laisser
les soignants caillasser je ne peux pas
laisser l'accès au service public
entravé
après il y a des questions avec les
familles il y a le sujet de l'ilrisme je
recevais le patron de l'ANCLI vous avez
vu que Gabriel LAL hier a lancé un
bouquet de proposition je proposerai
naturellement que les territoires
ultraarins quand on regarde les
résultats il pote pas du Doig parce
qu'il y a d'autres territoires dans
l'Hexagone où c'est pas très brillant
non plus on doit pas simplement à l'âge
de 16 ans mais dès l'âge de 4 5 ans
parce que les violences elles démarrent
là et vous avez dit il y a beaucoup de
Français concernés VO pas
deustracisation non plus je vais vous
dire il faut qu'on baptise quelque chose
de nouveau moi j'aurais besoin de vous
j'aurais besoin de vous parce que sans
les maires sans les parlementaires sans
les élus de proximité c'est pas à Paris
qu'on va décider vousvez vu que la fois
dernière je suis venu à Mayotte j'ai
essayé d'apporter un peu de rayon de
soleil puisque j'ai amené le avec moi le
directeur général de la cosmétique
vallée il y a une cosmétopie formidable
une pharmacopie formidable pour dire
qu'il y a des leviers de croissance
extraordinaire à chaque fois je ve
arriver avec un bout de rayon de soleil
et là-dessus moi j'ai besoin je
dis au sénateur c'est mon abréviation il
n'en veut pas n'est-ce pas euh mais de
dire que j'ai besoin de vous deux parce
que vous étiez aussi et vous êtes aussi
des élus locaux chevronnais et c'est par
les milieux associatif c'est par le
maillage des proximités c'est avec les
maires qu'on arrivera à faire les choses
c'est pas nous qui avons décidé à Paris
donc bâtissons ensemble sur l'idtrisme
sur les violences et vous savez même que
avec le préfet j'ai même rencontré des
jeunes la semaine dernière très tôt le
matin dans deux villages où il y a eu
une bagarre généralisée et je leur ai
dit que voilà moi j'ai vécu ça dans ma
commune donc je peux vous dire on va
essayer ensemble d'avancer comptez sur
moi le resma c'est génial on est à plus
de 600 il y aura des formations
complémentaires à porter et nous sommes
à deux doigts de conclure avec la croix-
rouge une nouvelle école de formation
d'infirmierrie d' soignant à maotte à la
sortie du resma j'essaie de faire les
chîn en mancant voilà pour répondre à la
fois la carence sanitaire et l'absence
de soins il y aura des bonnes nouvelles
annoncées par la première ministre
demain naturellement lui appartient les
dévoiler surtout pas à moi mais vous
dire que pleinement pris en cause euh
pour c'est Futuna vous n'êtes pas le
petit caillou du jardin qu'on voit
pas le qu euh je connais ça par cœur
votre préfet et mon ancien secrétaire
général de roir donc le sujet bancaire
je vais le prendre à bras le corp parce
que ça ça m'agace grave et je vais voir
la présidente de laassation française
des banques c'est scandaleux ce qui se
passe je vous dis tel que je le
pense et je sais que ce matin il y a
encore un contact qui est en train
d'être pris entre le directeur duf n na
le préfet et les entrepreneurs je vous
ai promis que je viendrai j'aurais dû
venir je vous expliquer désolé hein
c'était pas ma volonté mais j'ai été
détourné c'est normal Gérald devait
aller ailleurs impérativement donc nous
sommes répartis de travail je viendrai
je prendrai le temps et comme c'est loin
je prendrai un peu plus de temps encore
et et en tout cas je vais pas attendre
le mois de janvier pour m'occuper de ça
là je pars à maot je rendre Sami matin
je pars à sa piierre et miclon je rentre
mercredi mercredi ou jeudi je vous
promets de commencer à bouger fort sur
ce sujet ça n'est pas
acceptable Monsieur génateur paomier
Merci pour vos mots de d'encouragement
et de bienveillance qui qui me touche
beaucoup mais vous me connaissez bien la
sensibilité là vous dire aussi que je
pense vous avez prononcé quelque chose
de très important c'est comment on
considère que les territoire ultramarin
ce n'est pas uniquement une destination
de vacances quoi pour faire
simple comment on a un at mené ensemble
parce que vous faites partie de cette
délégation dont j'ai fait partie à
l'Assemblée entre 2017 et 2022 je l'ai
dit dans une chaîne de télévision
l'autre jour à la Réunion où cétait un
peu chaud dans le avec un journaliste
qui me disait la France est propriétaire
des territoires ultramarins non mais
attendez faut vous retournez en 6e quoi
non mais on est où la franceitit marin
n'est pas la France et l'é marin sans la
France ça n'existe pas non plus voilà
donc il faut trouver cette intelligence
collective avec avvec des évolutions
institutionnelles j'ai entendu le
sujet 5 sur 5 je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que le Président de la
République et puisqu'on m'a posé la
question sur les personnes été qualifié
ils auront ils aont la rencontre de tous
les territoires ils veront tous les élus
il veront tous les parlementaires parce
que quoi qu'il arrive si a une réforme
institutionnelle à priori se fait AC les
parlementaires c'est juste un un élément
n'est-ce pas madame la sénatrice c'est
juste moi j'oublie pas ça je suis all à
Versaille qure fois dans ma vie donc je
n'oublie pas et donc pour répondre à
Jean-Gérard prier oui c'est un challenge
et j'ai envie de vous dire
je ne renvoie pas la balle mais
peut-être qu'entre la délégation
ultramarine de l'Assemblée et du Sénat
c'est peut-être un beau sujet madame la
Présidente me permet de
je n'avais pas du tout réfléchi à ça
voir comment on pourrait peut-être
essayer d'imaginer quelques leviers euh
pour voir justement quel est l'intérêt
enfin moi j'ai l'intérêt en matière
d'écologie de transition écologique en
matière de sauvegarde de planéte TER en
matière de rayonnement économique ça a
été prononcé par beaucoup d'entre vous
parce que lorsqu'on est en Martinique en
Guadeloupe et ben on fonctionne avec la
Dominique on fonctionne Réublique
dominicaine on fonctionne avec Cuba on
fonctionne avec les États-Unis
d'ailleurs ça me permet de dire que sur
initiative de la sénatrice il y a des
jeunes étudiants Martinique et
guadeloupé 1 pour certains on aura un
premier petit créneau cette année voyz
on tente une expérience qui pourront
aller peut-être qui pourront aller s'ils
le souhait aux États-Unis se former et
revenir on va pas obligatoirement les
envoyer à 9000 km ou à 6000 km oui c'est
on a mis un petit peu dessous là-dessus
je vois que le sénateur tu au fil France
le sourcil non mais vous voyez je j'ai
essayé de lancer des expérimentations
parce que que je tiens votre amendement
pardon excusez-moi non mais sénateur
thophile pardon mais il m'en veut pas
mais c'est que c'est la bienveillance
absolue lu dire que je sais sa
sensibilité pour faire en sorte que les
forces vives soient formé et reviennent
au pays et donc je tiens à cela et je
tiens ça d'une oui j'ai appris ça quand
j'étais très jeune en région auverne un
ancien président de la République avait
lancé ça pour des jeunes étudiants qui
sortant de l'école de commerce avaient
la possibilité d'aller se former un an
aux États-Unis il y en a un qui est
devenu depuis directeur général des
outrum Olivier Jacob pour pas le citer
donc on apprend des belles expériences
donc je me propose monsieur le sénateur
qu'on regarde ça ensemble madame la
présidente Madame la Sénat concon pardon
juste une chose sur l'INC
euh la mission autreemaire je tiens à
vous dire on finance 400000 € par an
d'étude si la question que vous me posez
c'est de savoir si on peut voir un
moment ou un autre monie tavnier voir
comment on peut être plus efficace sur
les études oui je l'ai vu hier
derilleèur avec un des directeurs des
autres mes on a une bonne relation de
travail pour savoir comment sur le
chiffrage des mayottes m'était engagé
comme je repars on essaie d'avancer je
crois que notre discussion était loin
d'ê inutile ils m'ont d'ailleurs dit si
vous voulez qu'on soit meilleur
aidez-moi avec les maires et les élus
c'est pour ça que je me suis permis
devant vous retransmettre oui madame la
sénatrice qu'on a les éléments
d'appréciation encore plus factuel en
tout cas moi tout ce que vous voulez me
demander j'essaierai de vous le donner
en transparence absolue avec vous enfin
Madame la Présidente la loi 3DS je vois
que vous n'avez rien oublié sur les
fameux rapports de juillet 202 2 alors
là je suis un peu surpris qu'il n''est
pas été
transmis euh alors on me dit la dgom a
transmis sa contribution au ministère de
la Santé le relie j'ai pas vu ce
document là écoutez en tout cas je
m'engage devant vous à accélérer les
choses parce que lorsqu'on doit un
rapport au Parlement mais pas un an et
demi transmettre je vous dis les choses
très clairement voilà le Parlement quand
même quelque part doit être respectecter
voyez j'ai pas oublié mes vieux réflexes
donc je les conserverai donc je donne
pour mon équipe qu'on puisse bien
avancer sur cette question là et je
crois avoir répondu je l'espère le
calendrier vous avez une idée du
calendrier des travaux des experts alors
le calendrier des travaux des experts on
terminera si vous m'autorisez sur ce
sujet là parce que faut pas que
pas faire gronder là j'ai pas
complètement la main euh le président
pour l'avoir vu hier m'a confirmé que
dans les prochains jours une nomination
interviendrait euh je pense que dans la
première partie de l'année 2024 on aura
une très belle avancée et quoi qu'il
arrive les parlementaires seront
naturellement auditionner
l'objet la possibilité pour eux
d'apporter une contribution donc qui
permettra je crois un bon éclairage mais
ces sujets là sont assez preignants
depuis longtemps et je pense que la
méthode qui a été choisie me paraît
assez pertinente parce que elle
permettra de de se mettre à l'écoute des
territoires moi j'ai pu dire ça et des
des attentes écouter des attentes une
fois de plus je pense que c'est chaque
territoire qui doit décider de ce qu'
doit faire par exemple et je terminerai
par maotte mais on voudrait pas d'avoir
beaucoup d'affection pour ce territoire
qui mérite d'être très largement soutenu
le Conseil départemental je parle sous
contrôle des deux sénateurs qui sont là
fait un gros travail et là la dgom a
fait un travail juridique très important
qui permet de distinguer à la fois ce
qui était du réglementaire ce quiétait
du législatif et ce qui était
éventuellement du Constitutionnel et
donc vous dire que dans les attentes que
vous pouvez exprimer en tant que
parlementaire il y a un certain nombre
de choses qui seront du régime
constitutionnel et d'autres qui seront
régime du réglementaire ou du législatif
et cette ligne ne partage des EAU parce
que quelquefis même les compétences sont
pas corèctement exercées donc profitez
de ce beau moment de dialogue avec des
personnalités qualifiées qui ne sonont
pas directement impliquer en vie
politique qui seront par essence des
personnes neutres et qui permettront de
recevoir votre vision donc faites-le
sans retenu merci en tout cas de de
m'avoir interrogé je voulais juste dire
au-delà de la délégation madame la
présidente que si vous voulez qu'à un
moment ou un autre sur une question
particulière sur l'octroit de mer sur
une comme ça sur n'importe quelle
question vous souhaitez que ici ou à
ouduno on a la capacité de se voir je
suis à votre disposition merci Monsieur
le Ministre merci à tous donc avant de
lever la séance deux messages déjà à 10h
tous les membres de la délégation sont
attendus au pied de de l'escalier pour
la traditionnelle photo et deuxième
point certains d'entre vous m'ont
sollicité pour faire passé demander la
priorité sur l'article 55 bien que
n'importe quel sénateur peut le demander
mais je répondrai favorablement à la
demande donc je ferai le point avec la
séance pour faire parer l'article 55 en
priorité voilà merci à
tous